welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have
some big news and coming in regards to
Falcon and Winter Soldier the show which
was announced in August 2009 teen is
currently being filmed and because of
this leaked images from the production
have slowly been making their way to the
web this morning subreddit Marvel
Studios spoilers dropped a whole host of
images of wire rustle who'll be playing
John Walker aka u.s. agent the actor was
filmed in both his military uniform and
Captain America s costume and it's
actually a lot that we can take from
this information throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
first look and talking about a report
that states that the Thunderbolts will
be introduced in the show as well now we
will be talking about some of the plot
leaks in regards to Falcon and Winter
Soldier and Black Widow so if you don't
want to know anything that I highly
suggest that you turn off now make sure
you subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up to help spread
the news
anyway if you didn't know u.s. agent was
actually introduced into the comics in
1986 as a villain known as super Patriot
over time this got sort of retconned and
he morphed and evolved into a
government-sanctioned Captain America
and this costume is clearly aping that
the Disney show is actually going to
follow on directly from the events of
Avengers endgame and if you remember the
end of the movie
Steve handed the shield over to Sam who
then took up the mantle of Captain
America now it looks like agent has the
exact same shield and while something
that this is a replica I personally
think that it is the shield that we saw
at the end of endgame according to the
leaks
salmon's are dropping the mantle after
realizing the trouble that calling
himself Captain America will cause
Falcon and Winter Soldier are still
outlaws at this point and even if they
did help save the universe from Thanos
that doesn't mean that general Ross is
giving them a free pass
we know that Steve was in hiding after
he travelled back in time in this
showcases that he had to lay low it
might be because he didn't want to bump
into his younger self but there's also a
lot of Tysons that kuvira cords are
flying about on the internet that states
he hid because he knew the government
after him what I think happened and bear
in mind that this is a theory and said
Sam got the shield the government went
after him and Bucky arrested them and
then created their own Captain America
and made it seem official by taking the
shield from Sam and giving it to Walker
the shots here look like some sort of PR
stunt and this could be them announcing
to the world that it doesn't have to
live in fear
after the apparent death of the cap as
they have someone else in place that
looks very similar to him just stop
worrying look you've got blond hair and
blue eyes yeah is Captain America when
you think about it I think it's gonna be
funny seeing how the government kind of
spin this and I think the image of him
in his military attire is taking place
before these shots and from the leaks we
do know that these are two separate
scenes that white filmed and that they
happen at different points in the series
so yeah just kind of drawn conclusions
and sort of stating the obvious my
superpower is stating the obvious
either way though there is a lot to
process here and it looks like the MCU
will be skipping the super patriarchy
and going straight to the
government-sanctioned Captain America
motif they are clearly trying to ape him
due to the similarities in the costume
and I am excited by the looks of this
Wyatt's father Kurt already appeared in
the MCU as one of the more notable dads
in the saga and it's great that his sons
getting to make an appearance too as for
the Thunderbolts this report comes from
full circle cinema there's actually a
lot of weight to it so we already know
that Daniel brew will be returning as
emo and in the comics he has been a
member of the team at some points
however in addition to this the report
says that though it isn't clear of
exactly how the Thunderbolts will appear
they know they will be introduced or at
least teased this lines up a lot with
recent leaks on Black Widow that dropped
earlier in the week from a 4chan user
that apparently saw the film as part of
a test group now we will be going into
the post credits scene of that film and
what the user said so if you don't want
to know turn off now but yeah thanks for
making it this far anyway according to
the user the film ends with Yelena
biloba played by Florence Pugh and
taskmaster going to general Ross with a
flash drive that is the big MacGuffin of
the Phil
ruslan says he's putting a team together
and this of course teases the
Thunderbolts with both Widow and Falcon
and Winter Soldier dropping this year I
can see the two tank together and it
makes a lot of sense to start setting
them up across all the releases Zemo is
a big part of the Thunderbolts and with
the news of this it looks like it's all
slowly falling into place
I'm very hyped now and I can't wait to
see the Thunderbolts on the big screen
especially if we get Red Hulk in some
form or another the rumors that it will
be a Disney Plus show but I am kind of
hoping for a movie but yeah we'll just
see when it's released Marvel are
putting a lot into the streaming service
and with their recent rebrand of the TV
properties now going under the umbrella
Marvel Studios TV there is a lot to look
forward to now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the news and if
you're excited for what's coming comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the black widow leaks which
are gonna be linked at the end we go
over everything you need to know about
the first review and the plot spoilers
of the movie so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you can support the show by subscribing
to us and patreon and if you want to
come chat to us after the video then
join our discord server in the
description below or follow us on
twitter at definition whitey that's the
best way to keep up to date with
everything we do at heavy spoilers and
hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like it subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]